but here's this story the CEO of Amazon
Jeff Bezos the richest man in the world
is accusing the National Enquirer and
its publisher of extortion and blackmail
now this move dramatically escalates a
dispute with the tabloid that exposed
intimate details of his private life he
may remember The Enquirer revealed Bezos
his longtime affair with former TV
anchor Lauren Sanchez that was last
month well then the billionaire used his
private investigators to set out to
learn well just how did all of his text
messages and some pictures with Sanchez
how were they obtained last night
Bezos posted on the blog medium what
appeared to be he emails from the
Enquirer's publisher American Media Inc
those emails urged him to stop the
investigation or risk having private
photos and other texts become public
Jericka Duncan is following this
extraordinary story and the dispute that
also has a political dimension Eureka
good morning good morning Bezos had a
lot to say in that post last night Bezos
says am i's latest offer came because
its CEO David pecker was furious about
the investigation but now the world's
richest man is fighting back publicly
and he says despite the personal cost
Jeff Bezos is on the offensive after
hiring a team of investigators to find a
national enquires and its parent company
am i's motives for unveiling his affair
Bezos now says they tried to intimidate
and silence him in a combative blog post
Bezos revealed what he says our emails
from a.m. eyes attorneys telling him to
cease and desist from his personal
investigation in one email am i chief
content officer Dylan Howard allegedly
threatened to release photos including a
below-the-belt selfie if he didn't
comply in another ami deputy general
counsel John fine
allegedly asked Bezos and his lawyers to
announce that they have no knowledge or
basis for suggesting that America
media's coverage was politically
motivated in exchange it said ami agrees
not to publish distribute share or
describe unpublished texts or photos
Bezos who also owns the Washington Post
believes the decision to unveil those
messages
was politically motivated he wants
political influence so that Amazon will
benefit from it and could relate to his
very public spat with President Trump
who just last month referred to him as
Jeff bozo the president has a
long-standing but recently turbulent
relationship with Ami and its CEO David
pecker last year the company admitted to
federal prosecutors that it made hush
money payments during the 2016 campaign
to a former Playboy model making
allegations of an affair with mr. Trump
that agreement prevents prosecution for
the payment unless they commit more
crimes
Lachlan mark' is an investigative
reporter for The Daily Beast who first
reported Bezos investigation we don't
know if they've committed crimes in this
case but that's certainly what Jeff
Bezos seemed to be suggesting and it's
something that I anticipate prosecutors
will certainly ask David Becker about
and it could really blow back on am I in
a big way
well we reached out to American media
incorporated and its legal
representatives for comment but they
have not responded however they have
long said their reporting is not
influenced in any manner politically or
otherwise it's letter is extraordinary
terrific I mean when he says in my
position if I can't stand up to this
kind of extortion how many people can
but my favorite line is I also won't
participate in their well-known practice
of blackmail political favors I prefer
to stand up roll this log over and see
what crawls out and it's a game changer
I think and that's what deal with the
National that's what question what
crawls out just who was behind the leak
of this information Gavin de Becker very
expensive well-known security person for
billionaires has told The Washington
Post that Jeff Bezos does not believe
that his phone was hacked he thinks that
that it's possible that a government
entity might have gotten hold of his
text messages the question is which
government entity the US a foreign
government and for what reason and
that's what's really fascinating about
this whole thing and he also closes the
door to anybody who's questioning his
leadership style saying look at what I
did with this company I employed 600,000
people it's the most valued company in
the world yes almost a team of
investigators and has given them an open
checkbook which means there's
they tuned you will be on the story
Jericka yes